come probabilmente sapevate già tutti e
se non lo sapevate sapevatelo io e
sabrina siamo stati invitati a parigi
per la finale italiana della just dance
world cup
lì siamo volati a parigi con play la
finale italiana è già stata fatta e
abbiamo già eletto il vincitore che
andrà alla finale mondiale la finale
mondiale sta per arrivare ragazzi quindi
io non vedo l'ora sono l'ambasciatore
italiano appunto ancora non ci credo di
aver avuto questo onore qui log ero
assolutamente anche la finale mondiale è
obbligato anche la finale italiana che
state per vedere in questo momento vi
lasciarlo da ragazzi dormi dormi nord
che qui ci pensiamo noi
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti in
questo nuovo video dio sono famiglie e
elefanti e anche tu sì ma io sono quello
dei rom e oggi andiamo a parigi fare
[Musica]
andiamo a fare le finali nazionali della
world cup di just dance
venite con noi che programmi avete sotto
dormi dormi dormi e iscriviti al nostro
caso punto mette ansia da 1 a mille
volare quando piove qualche ragazzino
interrati in aeroporto io puntualmente
attivo la videocamera in questo momento
così mi sequestrano anche la famiglia
eccolo il nostro all'acqua chiazza
insiste dei ragazzi l'ace scrittore in
su studi voi prendete il taxista
la pista è mio esattamente come luca
raga abbiamo il v anno però stavolta
grazie a dio non ho la testa da unicorno
quindi vedo vedo sabri che blocchiamo la
stessa cosa
guarda il tettuccio la facciamo
ammettiamo lorenzo per da vedetta e
passiamo sotto un ponte molto basso il
ii era sorti nero a ruba le emissioni
nocive galatina in puglia di dover
ripieni sa capire le garçon cioccolata
calda siamo entrati negli studios in
fabbrica il camerino
ma no e io ho il camerino a non so il
west ma sono fa vj sono marcello
bacchetta sarebbe sacchetto però hanno
scritto bacchetta bacchetta invece
sacchetta pare ammira quello che il mio
l'hanno scritto giusto e se il mio
camerino lama donde di colore il signore
la barba 6 tutto c'è nel tuo posto sono
io sono io quando mi crescerà la barba e
lo statuto a giudicarne ma visti i
ballerini entrerà in scena lorenzo
ostuni meglio chiamato è conosciuto come
favi c'è niente vediamo le gambe di favi
j
eccolo eccolo ragazzi siamo nel camerino
io e sapri ci stiamo allenando per per
fare i giudici di lanzano io sto
guardando cattivissimi sto guardando il
video di garrison fare una cosa un po
più fluido fare un movimento più fluido
per prova
no no no ci devi essere in forma leggera
come piume leggere come piume come piume
sabrina perfetta ciao fratti per
giudicare vai a guardarli come guarda
che quadretto perfetto
siamo venuti a parigi per dormire non
devo fare il tester di giovani avete
mentito menzogne quasi po diverso dalla
sabbia sono passati circa quattro ore la
prima mal tipo dall'ism al mose giudice
ci ha lasciato il posto lui cioè se ci
ha lasciato il posto lech e importante
vado io mai sulla sua sedia
grazie per le poste aver mi sento mi
sento certo tu paradiso
sì anche se vice intendente che non si
parla di passato alla porta esatto se il
medesimo
mi dispiace che se con questi due dice
di comprendere le nuove corse passi cosa
che abbiamo in campiano
quando io ero piccolo da un diario nel
diario c'erano alle gabbie tutti i
giorni e sotto il giorno generale che il
personaggio pubblico corso compleanno e
hanno colto al giorno e praticamente
m'ha dato del vecchio anche del vecchio
tesa a nicole come pezzi di superare
questa sfida ok fantasy ha regalato
giovini siti concorrenti perché
movimenti fluidi pensa che credi dopo
aver visto questo sta rinnegando tutti i
suoi anni di danza
mamma mia mio nonno che avanza fa meglio
[Musica]
brava elisa bravissima elisa ma non è
tutto non cantare vittoria perché
abbiamo ancora diventati
qui si rifà le maniche è stata veramente
sensazionale e faceva un po l'effetto
più ma i clienti invece se la guardo
sono d'accordo sembra con ostacoli
entrambe però c'era una cosa che sommano
in più
i ragazzi da qui in avanti iniziava la
finale italiana le ragioni si vuole cup
che ovviamente non posso mettere perché
non vi posso spoilerare andrà in onda il
7 dicembre alle 8 e 10 sul canale 31
quindi in realtà in guardatevela perché
veramente c'era veramente la
competizione qui c'è la vera sono stati
bravissimi ragazzi alla fine c'è stata
un vincitore o vincitrice perché non può
sospettare ha reso ha vinto maschi e
femmine però è stato veramente
combattuta quindi guardatevi poi la
puntata quando quando sarà al 7 dicembre
di persona ho visionato anche la
versione di just dance 2018 che è una
figata incredibile è soprattutto lo
pensano anche elisa e nicole sono state
braille loro sono stati bravissimi io
spero solo che siete d'accordo sul sulla
scelta del vincitore che sarà poi colui
che rappresenterà l'italia alla finale
mondiale quindi io spero ragazzi che il
video vi sia piaciuto cose iscrivetevi e
ho perso
eccolo qua e non ci vediamo ma non
possiamo
[Musica]